can I ask you a question what where's
your whoop my whoop yeah my womb
where's your whoop I worked this morning
I didn't charge it decided to leave it
on the charger but you can charge it you
can charge on the go but it's my phase I
don't want to distract the viewers I
don't want it's five days five days to
do I hiked I hiked on Friday yeah eight
miles yeah [ __ ] my pants even calculated
that yeah everything I'm a mouse tells
you how far you go dpi so as you're
hiking you're whoop will tell you either
tell me my exact my heart rate humming
it also tells you mile a mile oh yeah
everything dude I'm telling you there's
nothing there's not another tracker on
the planet that's as detailed and has
multiple kind of functions heart rate
rest output everything it's got that
Bluetooth Low Energy everything dude
okay dead connects with third-party
devices yep connect someone it's got the
software improvements it's got the
strain Coast gives you training level
recommendations based on your bodies
recover it banzz
it's got snap plus overlay live heart
calories live strain in real time with
your phone uses videos to analyze your
performance or share with a coach or on
social media and Tony man there's
nothing like it
wow you rock it you find out you get all
your output in what what now now can I
get a little promo here can I get a
little dude what I'm gonna do I'm saving
$30 okay you go to woop woop has
provided the tea fat Kate are me
listeners thirty hours off they're
purchased with the code fighter just go
to whoop calm Tommy WH o Opie dot-com
use the code fighter at checkout safe
$30 and optimize the way you train again
that fighter
whoop calm promote fear iLike it good I
do a lot of times is I gotta do this
[ __ ] you shut up chasing else shut up
Jay bro why do you always match your hat
in your pants now huh oh is it marrying
well oh whoops yeah I just put this
outfit together oh and your skin's
mustard I said it on Bassano that's
racist no your skin your Auster do you
have John or you don't know for certain
I live now cuz that's racist you said I
have yellow skin no that's not what I
said
well my
of a gas evasion we're already in
trouble you're in trouble you're in
trouble
I like how I did getting on a race I got
a lot of Asian American people that hit
me up and they were pissed not only were
they pissed they were like I'm not
listening to the show anymore God but
but I understand because I think it's a
no hold on don't say this no please Lord
Steve I said this before I've said that
people always forget cuz because Chinese
Americans Chinese expat Chinese all over
the world have done incredibly well in
every in every culture Koreans have done
incredibly well Vietnamese done
incredibly well in every culture they've
embedded themselves in okay and I've
always said that they we don't talk
enough about how much they've been
discriminated okay but their culture
seems to be the kind of culture that
gets them to excel the boys were Harvard
is see they're suing Harvard on a
class-action suit because apparently
Harvard things are too many quote
unquote Asians I understand I understand
I've said that before having said that
let's go back to whether or not somebody
should lose their job because they made
a comment from what I heard I'm doubling
down from what I heard it's not like he
said this is what other people say about
that particular house yeah he kind of
doubled down if anything he and I've
said this from the jump he should have
been fired for having a bad podcast the
problem is it wasn't funny
and it was like reckless and I get they
just wasn't funny but I did have some
asian-americans I think they're
asian-americans could just be Asians DM
me and go Brennan get your opinion all
good
how would you feel if you use the n-word
replace what he said the [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I like saying it but replace [ __ ] Reese
and word would you still defend them
what oh I wouldn't they went in that way
like I literally had this dialogue this
guy goes in that we're telling you I
think it's all good because they [ __ ]
cuz you don't think that says why do you
think it was good I don't use I don't
know I don't say it's good but I didn't
think you but they go even if he was
saying out of context the n-word would
you still defend my oh I wouldn't well I
went oh I guess
well I did I think I kind of get I think
you can say any word depending on
context me well I don't think and use
the n-word well I I think you can use
the n-word if you use it needs a context
right also I see I don't think you can't
that's fine
but but I I would see I don't think you
can but I also think it up because it's
a product of the environment I grew up
in yeah and I was young gotcha
where is mainly african-american so like
that word carried so much way yeah you
gotta be careful y'all watch your P's
and Q's yes so to me I'm like I would
never the reason I wouldn't use that
word that I've never used that word okay
[ __ ] or whatever a month the f-word vim
whatever it is I don't want to make
people feel bad and I'm very aware it's
derogatory I'm very aware it was used in
a very derogatory also guess what but
now I don't do that because I don't I
don't do it because I'm gonna get in
trouble I don't do it because I am aware
that it hurts people's feelings that is
shitty and I don't want to be that guy
how is it possible that this guy is not
racist
what said was saying he was using it in
how people say that particular house is
now a little Brody did tell me if you
keep going back there's worse stuff than
this so they like if it wasn't this it
would've been something so he's
insensitive but not race he's also
really good comic you know but that was
the problem with that where you don't
see like very many good community
failing him because they thought [ __ ]
yeah well what I would say is this he's
he's insensitive scold him and get him
get him to see like educate the dude get
to get him to see hey hey dude hey hey
this this sucks this sucks for the
history here's a history behind this
word this is what it was like to be
chinese-american it's what it was like
to be korean-american this is what the
[ __ ] in history this country where its
socked where you were a third-class
citizen a second okay but but when you
fire somebody when you say you're out to
me that's cancel culture and to me
you're not making the world a better
makes it worse right
but also it is how about this so we're
in the parking lot of the comedy store
last night all the comics while we're
all talking and we're talking about this
situation we were with Tim Dylan who is
a gay man right yeah and that's I'm not
outing that the
but it's well documented so we're all
talking a group Santino Tim some other
guys daliyah's there Brian Brian comes
up in his Tesla I always make fun of
Brian instead I don't if you even
noticed this Brian come is Tesla I make
a remark about how Jade is driving the
Tesla front of Tim damn it and the other
guy I think is his boyfriend
I don't know how might be his boyfriend
I didn't like yell out a derogatory term
of driving a Tesla now it's a bit wasn't
Roger are you said gay I said yeah but
you in a dirt but in a way that was way
harder on me yeah yeah making fun of you
but because of Brian but I don't have a
I don't have listen i think Tess is
great I think the technology behind it
spinning silly that's the future playing
we always we always joke around in my
Aston Martin was there and park in front
of it so it's a bit we always do and
yeah daliyah's in on it yeah but Tim's
there who's a gay man I said it and as
it was come now it you [ __ ] yeah
whatever everyone laugh Tim laughter
when laughed but all I could think about
the whole night the whole night I get
home right around midnight or whatever I
text him I go dude I know we're comics I
don't say a lot of [ __ ] I probably need
to tell you this but just to make me
feel better
because I'm a narcissist just make me
feel better when Brian pull up in this
Tesla I called it gay I feel terrible
about it and I wait wait wait then I get
back bredren
listen you definitely don't need to
apologize for that I get rid of coming
from you're not home look like you know
he's cool about it he's also he's such a
dude and he hangs out with nothing but
straight I loved him like yeah unless he
told you you wouldn't it he'd be like no
smile Isaac fo but there was I do it I
get it you want to keep him included and
you don't want hurt no he's our friend
yeah you don't wanna [ __ ] know it
always comes down to me it always comes
out of not hurt anybody's feelings
yeah I was like I just don't want I know
like rock so he's not gonna acknowledge
it there that hurt his feelings but what
if it did and then he's new you know
he's kind of newer to the thing he's
around so I don't want to be like I'll
[ __ ] you know look here's about of mine
I think you should always be able to
apologize it's so at the times I've
heard people's feelings whether the men
are women whether that I misread
something and and I I know I got a call
from somebody said you know you treated
me this way and I think it was a shitty
way
I called them so quickly because
I decided it wasn't about getting in
trouble I just didn't want I don't want
bad energy I didn't want them to feel
bad man I don't I want to be like I'm
sorry there's nothing what I was saying
I'm sorry there's nothing wrong with
being like I didn't [ __ ] know I did I
[ __ ] up they said by the way we're
allowed to go I [ __ ] up I'm sorry I
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
yeah but I yet I care what my friends
think yeah and that's it you can't you
can't satellite to your PB you also
don't want to lend yourself to the
chorus of pile on you want to be piling
on somebody who's already been made fun
of historically you know so r08 I grew
up around my cousin was murdered for
being gay like I'm very sensitive
yeah they had that they had nothing to
do with that fact and here's the thing
Tim with a quiet night what the [ __ ]
you might be gay you know what I mean
what do you I'm saying what the promise
he went well the problem is it's Brian's
a very gay 51 year old man no no 52 you
throw that to Adam
you know I did no no because you live in
this truth now no no but you might know
and I it's really when you're drunk
you're drunk maybe you do stuff you know
what I mean maybe you do stuff who knows
you've made a pass at me
that's how dare you we were drunk and I
and you went you you're good or
something like that now right and you
were towering over me I went dude can I
take your neck and fold it over my dick
can I tell you something did I feel what
it feels like truly really circumcised
listen I really mean this what if I took
the skin of your dick and put it on mine
so I had a hood just took your neck skin
that's called hooding no it's called
uncircumcised it's called hooding I just
want to feel it it's called hooding
putting a hoodie on
yeah it's called Knight nut I believe
truly in the heart that if that when you
do have your gay experience and you will
and you probably have that you are on
the bottom you don't like being dominant
dude I do I'm a dominant I'm a [ __ ] at a
Playboy
you we dated you be younger and I would
be how [ __ ] ironic
I'm guarantee I'd be top the twink would
be tough you're not shave and you go
don't shave daddy keep it being uh call
me daddy I like to feel silly call me
daddy
let me feel sick then I'd be like and
you gotta lose I'm all sticky right now
dude I was hiking again nice three-hour
hike yeah answer the door never seen
your feet I have some dogs got some
never seen your feet before yeah but
you've seen me limp like this around I
walk like I'm Dan Henderson well cuz you
got you got to bro especially and you
know what's caused it not the hike and I
think it's me being on the bike all time
with my foot in the locked position
and then I Drive it's like that - we're
gonna go do ourselves some little stem
cell with renew its called renew I know
how about ask the lady who does it I go
oh so I have in my foot do you just
shoot it anywhere and they get to the
flesh she goes oh oh no we shoot it
right where you need the paint so if
it's in your heel will take a large
needle that's gonna shoot it into your
heel on it I don't think that's gonna
hurt I'm already [ __ ] up over that I'd
rather just keep the pain in my heel now
so many people have reached out if I
iced and I say a topic it kind of gets
better but there's ways to completely
give up I want to see what happens with
stem cells I want to see if if I get you
know I things that happen for you what
nothing
really no but you look and feel exactly
I don't I drop but Rogan and my buddy
Joey had they say they swear by a half
cook yeah I know a lot of here you know
cuz they're on the MRI with Rogan his
label that is true which is you didn't
need surgery that's kind of crazy I'm
gonna say how how well everyone now
that's off those crowd chambers and
trust me I was an athlete for a long
time I've done it all those don't do
[ __ ] hate to tell you well so jump in an
ice bath you want you want help yeah
jump in and those are super cheap but
guess what it's not all technology
advanced and the cool thing and they're
steamed ice bath anti-inflammatories ice
baths there you go right but also ice
baths anti-inflammatory a little dicey
but ice baths alright ice bath and
hydrate it seems like every ounce of
beef every athlete does it oh why does
every major program have ice bet yeah
cuz they work mmm or cold now they have
cold tubs so you'll cold tub hot soak
Ryan cryo chambers we're just basically
marketing I've done a cryo chambers yeah
dude they're like it's not like an ice
bath I've done not even close eyes well
get your body doesn't stop it there's
nothing like an ice bath how do you know
that made the Walkman
I've done it well I like when Brendan
was that people were talking about cryo
and Brendan was alone and he goes like
she goes in my experience but I I don't
know a lot I did do some sports
have been around really good athletes
most of my life but only till I was 30
not a big deal in my experience of 30
years of sports I have noticed at the
highest level and maybe I'm wrong that
they don't do cryo chambers they do ice
baths and that you haven't are ski well
you guys don't do oh that's all I got
here it's always the ice baths been
around since day one the ice bath dude
this plantar fasciitis like I don't know
dude I don't [ __ ] know I gotta stop
you got that I got that going on and
then we were talking about it I have the
Mesa I think it's called me Sophie Leah
it's where the sound of crunching will
ruin my day
the cat was crunching on some didn't
hear it but you mentioned I'm like well
that continues I'm have to leave I want
to take myself out of these so you don't
like if I were chewing crusty bread
crusty bread chips no I can't like if I
go to the movie theater at weird times
like I won't go when everyone goes if
the opening night I'll wait and going
like a Saturday afternoon when
everyone's already seen it
if there's somebody next to me eating
popcorn I'll have to leave the theater
that's not how it is really oh when they
these serve the vegetable tray plates
with like carrots and celery Rudi's hey
what are we doing like I get a leave I
can't I can't participate in oh you had
that back no audio at all don't make me
happy cuz I'm reading right now as is
pen clicking - yeah nuts and you guys
sent me so phony phony phony did they
say what it's from uh no is it a trauma
thing with when I was a kid with my dad
could evoke I'm hiking in freedom my son
has my son has an auditory thing a lot
of kids are blond delays yeah so so my
son even if the dog is outside barking
my son will flip the [ __ ] does it say
we're me so feel it comes from me so
fonio misophonia my daughter had to stop
me because I was like sappy and my [ __ ]
my daughters Bryant when he hears things
it you know Brian she goes dad if when
he hears things it's not like the way
you hear things some kids kids grow out
of it but the sounds can [ __ ] kids oh
I've been like this forever those her
forever something it's just a doll I can
is so if I'm in a movie theater I'll
literally it's all I can hear in focus
and I have to eating breathe up
breathing does drive me nuts
people screaming yep not I don't like my
kids screams I have to do something
about it
the brain sites of Miss Ophelia - when I
went hunting with Rogan I've never heard
snoring like that in my life I was like
hey Brad do it
how's that bro I started kicking him oh
you know Jay and I just share a room on
the road but he snores and I share a
room
no come on anymore oh no no we used to
anymore you have to have to separate
right now you snores I can't do it he
snores like a ma I need pure quiet talk
with some proms yeah I don't snore
man strong emotional reaction if you
have like anger there's a part of your
brain that just is more active when you
hear those sounds oh man there are some
good news though what's the good news
there's clinic sound listen I cognition
listen my heels been aching for years
I've done nothing about it you family
got a doctor four people crunching in my
now come on bro but I am gonna take you
to Vegas we're gonna get some stem cells
shot in our [ __ ] heels oh you do know
her heel no I mean you do do the heel
I'm gonna my dong and in my ankles my
Achilles heel hey I'd like to get it in
my lower back
yeah hey quit making up problems you
don't have problems correctly my neck is
all bunched no it's not it is you know
what stretch you don't do anybody I
don't know coming up with problems now
to get them still yeah that's right it
does dude I felt so bad for my son he
kept scratching this when I woke up kept
scratch I'm like dude quit scratching
scratch - got him skin off your arm and
I lift his little sleeve and yesterday
we were outside watering out the ficuses
we always water together at night I lift
up his little sleeve he has seven
mosquito bite just like you know it's
[ __ ] weird mosquitoes don't bite me
and everybody really only gets covered
in bites and I can be anywhere and they
just don't bite me ever have I get that
sweet nectar so my mosquitos don't like
my [ __ ] blood and my mother when she
would wake me up like we'd be and I grew
up all over the world she'd wake me up
like the Philippines where ever was
and the starving mosquitoes would be I
just attack her and I hit me once not
one you and Magic Johnson only to I know
bite you you sweat a lot yeah you do
I mean enough her this what I don't ever
like I'm Way more sweaty yeah yeah yeah
I'm what dude just you're wet I'm wet I
get wet I sweat on stage you know what
how about Tim Dylan you thought stage
after me last night goes in Brent shop
same diet both kiddo now doing it same
we're both killing it the crowd over so
last night I do a show right so I get
get get who's on the show so it's like
Joe Rogan and Friends
it's Gaffigan Jim Gaffigan yeah and but
and then mob sense you know the second
show I go I'll do the second show
because I was that got there late and
it's it starts with Bill burr then me
then Anderson Tina then Bert Kreischer
then Joe Roman it's not a bad shot he's
not a bad Shona when zyphus shows in the
world of it yeah
and that crowd was on fire yeah fire
yeah I love Jim Gaffigan we follow each
other on Instagram who is like each
other's [ __ ] and we never met and we're
I'm getting ready to go on the belly
room I'm you already go in the belly
room and the guy run the show goes Jim
Gaffigan here and we know he's looking
for a spot so if he does come up here
he's gonna bump you know it yes Jim
Gaffigan I'll go after Jim Gaffigan he
comes up my god okay here we go he's
going up and Jim goes and I don't we've
never met comes over just hello internet
friend
so buddy different everyone I was like
oh [ __ ] he's such a legend and you just
comes up has that big he's a big dude
yeah yeah it's gonna try and try out
white hat guy dude [ __ ] Midwestern
boy but Santa goes hello internet friend
to us laughing so he goes a little bit
about me I'm Korean
yes the best I come from Korea he's one
of the best I wish I was from Korea cuz
then my interest in Asian women wouldn't
be so creepy I'm from Indiana I know
you're thinking Indiana mafia he's one
of the better hilarious
it just I could I could not stop
laughing man made my night hello
Internet do you know buddy you do fall
each other but you're not sure if you
really know each other know is if he's
brother if I'm running it
his wife is a guy low internet friend
it's got a giant head do you haven't
having anxiety lately why oh yeah you
know why don't you want problems don't I
get my foot I can't listen people chew a
lot of coffee but you've been doing a
lot of coffee because when I drink that
coffee from funnel milk coffee
are you cause I get anxiety what'd I get
I'm all I'm all [ __ ] up on it now that
make coffee don't get bangs I love it
life gives me anxiety not coffee coffee
makes me happy or relaxes me that's so
much I drink so what what are you
anxious about my talk mutt they're
launching my tour this is a plug for it
either but my tour launches next week
I'm just seeing about it's just a lot
you know it's just a lot it's just a lot
it's just it's just a lot of dates away
from home yeah like tomorrow I gotta go
I usually fly out of Burbank way easier
for me this isn't me complain I'm just
talking about my life
everything's all good I just get anxiety
so you know you got to wake up like my
flight that's seven buts LAX it's gonna
leave around 4:30 I'm gonna drive from
Austin the Houston I don't know we got
kids when you got a kid it's just like
[ __ ] dude I know when you're trying to
find I get out all the dates like holy
[ __ ]
well you made you think about missing
him yeah yeah you missed a lot of [ __ ]
man
got another one on the way in November
that's why when I'm away with my kids
from daddy gets more than four days I
start to flip the [ __ ] out daddy gets
bills uh-huh yeah me too I like to get
myself in a position where I gotta make
the money I like the pressure I like a
little press I like you both I like
people counting on me and I like the
pressure whenever it's everything's all
good I like the rock the mom I need now
it's out another car yeah but you're
gonna doll
that [ __ ] uh that that Aston Martin
is you know I was me on the way here you
like to ask me that up that's a part for
you when I got here this is a car for
Callen
classy it's [ __ ] understated it
doesn't stick out it's a monster it's
special that's the car for you which DB
is it's just DB 11 how much is that car
don't worry about it an endorsement deal
I know but it's so expensive
it's a 2020 chin that's my exact garbage
god damn that's a nice car that's a car
for you dude really yeah I would like at
it I'm like oh this I don't know why I
thought about yes when I was driving
home I looked at an hour this right look
that I went that's that is the only car
I've ever seen that gets me kind of
excited yeah yours like your style like
it's R it's like understated like unless
you're a car gate really don't know what
they are it's not flashy drives very
well I like that it's not flashing but
it's having an amazing car it's in the
interiors like you had your right man
[ __ ] a Porsche for you [ __ ] all that
this is it right but it's it's got to be
over 200 ram it just depends you know
but it's in that area it's in that area
yeah it's in that depend which one you
get that could you just get the baby
that [ __ ] Glen the US the British
green is dope if I were to order one
cash I'd get a British green that yes if
I make enough money I'll get one of
those you get least one though and it's
all for work you know yeah but it's
still what would that be for at least
2,500 bucks a month $3,000 if you didn't
have a deal probably two grand well 2
grands really that's all I would think
it'd be a lot more than that what is it
give me the sticker on that give me give
me what it's cost so hard to get awesome
lp8 well there v8 twin-turbo the old
ones were a v12 201 2019
[Music]
there are excellent cars handmade
there's no what they only build like 700
months see that's the AMR though that's
the debt let's stop for Kelly yeah hey
no but no
yeah not for you leasing their one three
one three nine nine a month that's a lie
there's no way no good be go back maybe
some deal they got right there I'll go
there I'm gonna check it out
that's for the Vantage keeps going down
except apparently yeah but there you go
one 399 242 grand I mean it's not that
bad dude you scroll up oh yeah there you
go
Wow Sarah that's impressive
yes not bad that's very impressive the
car for you though I was thinking about
that do it for like if you want like a
supercar and that's a car I would drive
every day every that's your daily driver
reliable you know especially now they
did get a bad rap because Ford used to
they were going bankrupt and Ford bottom
and then four doesn't give a [ __ ] Saul
the hand stitching all that for what I
just tossed our parts into it see no I
you this $200,000 car and has like
plastic and but then they got bought
back out by some different owners who
ain't no no we're gonna keep it
everything handmade because that's a new
you looks like a piece of jewelry when I
looked inside it I was like oh my god
let me see the interior it's the James
Bond car right so yeah you're the
British greens my favorite one thing
people say about me is you're the
American James Bond that makes sense
that's the interior right there yeah
that's you all day killed all day yeah
as you got the Tiptronic bro
I've got Tiptronic hard to be doing this
you know what the biggest thing you know
how dare you nothing Tesla's new Prius
in LA no don't say that no one just oh
my dude look at Tesla I mean no one does
this Oh anymore no no I see Prius I see
Tesla don't say that no you have to take
that back
I told you that one time that guy
working for Tesla came up to my show
bought VIP came up just go don't a
picture do anything quit talking [ __ ]
about Tess left buy stock what yeah no
doubt he goes I go it's just a bit
because it's mean he hears no no I get
that we all listen the show man we work
at Tesla
quit talking [ __ ] man it's a great car
when did you understand the great guy
all my friends drive them I'm with you
man
it's just I'm not into electric cars
right now I well because Porsche making
one which is it's already better than
yours but the problem is I think I saw
one today even though it's so I'm tense
was gonna buy shoe red next to jeopardy
and we're Alex Trebek I think Alex
Trebek god bless him I think he's really
sick but I think he owns I think Porsche
gave him I take in because I saw a
Porsche Wow yes the only one yeah
they're they're dope oh let's see it's
got good reviews man no they're amazing
here's the problem though there's no
charging stations around so there's a
million so even Tesla the bit of a
problem with the charging station but
they're all over at Lane I don't know
where else in the in the you know
they're all over in LA but with Porsche
they're not all so but the charging so
much better than Tesla already the the
battery life and everything charges
faster and everything faster it's longer
so you have charged as much they're sick
looking though it's like I don't like to
car that be it I do feel though if I'm
gonna get that I'm just gonna get a
Porsche well that's it but that's but if
you like one yeah or I'll just get one
that runs on gas rush act like you know
what my biggest problem with this thing
is and this you got to be a real
gearhead here they call it turbo yeah
there's no turbo mmm-hmm why what it's
an electric car there's no you're lying
but why would you do that dr. Bob no to
make sense there's a 911 Turbo there's
911 Turbo S but then the what are you
doing Wow is this a tesla fighter but
tesla goes hold my electricity and
there's a big up there
they won out there's like they're
building another one to compete with
this cars are getting so outlandish so
outlandish a people can't drive I mean
like even my car I wrote ludicrous
horsepower what are you gonna do with
that
I can't drive like unless you're a
professional drive and you take all the
[ __ ] off you like you're not using that
or there's there's dodges that come with
a thousand horsepower there's Ferraris
that come with a thousand horsepower
these cars these electric cars are like
zero to 60 in like two seconds
then then pretty soon it's what like one
second aw come on you want you want your
[ __ ] kid driving across the 0-60 no
second side oh that's nuts
that's where we're headed like
everything's getting crazy everything's
so crazy
you don't have the skillset to drive it
my mother my mother who again can find
death everywhere my mother sends me a
video hard to watch it's all she says
hard to watch I get a video it's
accidents in China yeah because there's
so many people and there's seven hundred
fatalities a day and I'm like oh my I'm
one I'm watching the most horrific [ __ ]
why did my mother send me this why we
don't live there what why
what does anyone did you guys ever watch
you guys like watch the like Daniel
Pearl murder the no I don't watch south
Titus [ __ ] no oh wait there's not the
first guy I gotta keep decapitated Wall
Street report Walter who went there yeah
there's a great documentary on HBO and I
don't think I and they rename a school
over Daniel Pearl journalist school damn
pearls father is a very famous computer
scientist - what the the problem it well
it is a problem because he was the first
one murdered by with the kalam jihadi
john' the guy whose notoriety for
killing all the American journalists
yeah he was the one of the you know the
main ones that they killed but I
remember that was such a big deal
because when it happened they made the
video available just like anywhere mmm I
was working out all seasons rentals my
brother I mean a guy named Kurt who
passed away from cancer where he beat it
I'm not sure but I think he passed away
so let's keep it whether he passed away
shut up to that guy and he's my
brother's friend but I remember they
were what I can't watching us up but
they had a laptop and I just hear oh and
like what the [ __ ] are they watching and
I have my lunch and I go back there dude
it ruined my day it should work ruined
my week she's all like I don't do what's
the terrible thing I'll never I don't
watch it I can't watch that for I don't
out of respect and I accidentally saw a
virus you guys ever see that yeah I saw
one though the other one it was like a
hostage yeah and then I think it was
neat or something it was like one of the
very first ones that came out yeah and I
remember thinking I have to watch this
because this is important right I've
ever feel that way Isis propaganda and
then I saw a I'll never watch these Isis
propaganda that's what they wanted
still fear in you and he was a big he
was a big-time investigative journalist
look at spur always the bureau chief job
his father is one of the most brilliant
computer scientists in the world he was
it he went to Stanford he went to
Stanford
here's the thing though you know he went
out there got caught before they
released him they did some deal they
released them then he went back in then
he kept he went I think he went four or
five brave guy man his dad said was
ribbon on the thrill of it yeah he's
Israeli his father's Israeli so you know
these are yeah there's the Daniel Pearl
School of Journalism now up the street
it's like a high school it's pretty cool
shout Daniel Pearl yeah terrible story
though man his wife was quite beautiful
too I can't watch any of that stuff then
show his Wi-Fi cameras why she's like
this yes I pretty something I can't yeah
and they just got married do can you
imagine just the [ __ ] like it's just
anybody let alone take out your husband
and wife out of the equation or kids or
family verses if you had a friend who's
like dude he got captured by Isis you'd
like what the [ __ ] but here back then
when he got captured it wasn't to the
point where did like we know like oh
[ __ ] they're gonna execute that dude
here's what a journalist especially
here's what's interesting about Daniel
Pearl to is he was a gangster like all
the Americans that they captured yeah
they were they were you know that they
were taken prisoner and they would
starve them stuff and he would always
hide he'll hit stuff and he was like the
leader he's like don't worry we're gonna
be fine
like they said he was like the stone of
all of it i back and then people were
getting out and they're like aren't you
can really stand in Pearl and then that
I guess they kept them and I guess also
they would make like these Isis [ __ ]
would get bored and they'd make the
Americans fight each other like
cockfighting so they said they would
have to fake it but Daniel Pearl would
be like the ISIS were mean about like
they would kill you if you didn't do it
so I said Danny like just beat me up man
like he would always take it for the
team so no one else got hurt it's hard
bad he's [ __ ] are you talking about a
real hero you're facing death any
[ __ ] eyes in the worst form of it and
he was like no no let me take this man
yeah a real time out of
Real American Hero [ __ ] tragic man
handsome guy horribly horrible tragic
yeah and then how about the one I think
he was either Saudi Arabian or though
the one pilot does economy they
Jordanian they set on fire on fire
Jordanian guy yeah Isis a great guys now
they've been crushed they're [ __ ]
it's like oh you guys want you want to
play this game oh cool alright so we'll
just you want to take on who you want
take on the US the British jihadi john'
that the main guy doing it was like
getting forgotten right oh did they yeah
they blew his [ __ ] out man he cuz he
would go to the site where it used to do
most of the torturing so they were just
following him for a while fault I guess
Vermont foam he had no idea there's a
drone followed him everywhere and then
he gets to this little area where they
go oh he's there was a couple of his
boys and then [ __ ] smoke smoke that's
not so sure but you even taught like
some of the guys like it just wasn't the
justice that we wanted like they wanted
to get at that yeah I would love for a
couple of Navy SEALs to get a hold of
them oh yeah because before they hand
them over
then maybe SEALs are gonna do some
American justice like hey we're not
gonna find out about it but the boys
gonna take care you know I'm saying the
valise guys in the world will take care
I mean this guy jihadi John was just he
was a sociopath who got a chance to kill
people well young people like this are
drawn the psychos are drawn to any
movement like this where they're like I
get to kill people and it's and it's
legal I I'm in a group I get support
you're always gonna find and fortunately
in war the sociopaths the Psychopaths
come out and they they have an excuse to
do crazy [ __ ] Oh yep they're just
looking to kill people doesn't matter
here they're artists of pain you know
yeah
great documentary also an HBO jihadi
john' yeah oh yeah Ronan was talking
about he works now he's got Navy SEALs
who work the other great guys and he was
saying he was he's been around a lot and
it was like there's just a different
group they're just different do
and in the best way they're just so
[ __ ] squared away but I guess getting
through that [ __ ] you've just got to
have all your [ __ ] button down I mean
you know you're also gonna be your
hiring live hiring somebody who's gonna
be reliable yeah they're not gonna go
ridin in the face yeah they just are
there for a reason yeah yeah what is
this just the most famous Navy SEALs
marcus luttrell huge you know big time
guy and obviously the guy from American
sniper not Bradley Cooper Oh Chris Kyle
Chris gum ball huh
just badasses man yep I'm a badass to do
your better yeah I remember when I was
in doing comedy in Afghanistan and
Afghanistan and the amount of sleep we
got was very negligible and I was
thinking about the troop date yeah
everything but I just I was like man
these people and they'd meet us the next
morning I was like these people are
living on 2 and 3 hours of sleep a lot
of times and you would never know so
tough it's just like you're in a war
zone that's how easy here and then it
was so hot one day and this guy when you
get in the Humvee you can't get out
you're in your you're in your vest
you're in your hat it's so hot as no a/c
resume see what are you doing and but I
add to the fact that you could get hit
by an ie D anytime your suicide bomber
whatever might be and you're not getting
out of that that's that I mean there's
so many issues you can just die in a bad
way or get very injured and this dude
was it was so hot and I was in like a
t-shirt and he was in full gear and he
had just come back from you know he'd
been over the wire and he was in his
thing and I just looked at him and I go
you're not too hot or anything it's just
big guy it means let me just all good
bro I'm all fit and just I could just
just think you won't complain I know I
know I'm so hot you have a fans so we
can get a fan over here fellas yeah do
some curt offense sure so you kids got
going on this weekend
chin any plans
this weekend I'm probably gonna go to a
dog cafe a dog cafe and that's that it's
a place where you hang out with dog do
you have a dog puppies for like an hour
I do but he's at my parents house not
your dogs your parents sell my dog so
yeah but you don't live with you
so with me are you bringing the dog to
the cafe now you just go there and meet
new dogs yes that's much better than
gonna bargain girls what that's that's a
good way to spend your time there's any
girls there for sure sure yeah no Sam
where's this cafe you have a daughter
you ever have a dog cringe it though
it's low you have a Jindo yeah okay I
don't know yet you know me hey think
Rita it's in Koreatown I think I think
it's in Koreatown you know about did you
look yeah oh yeah oh yeah how do you
know but Robbie many moons ago now joke
small dogs but the fiercest medium-sized
me very very smart and there are dogs
there also it also protects you pretty
well very very well yeah yeah
Casa catering any plans you going to you
going with chin to the success no I am
NOT I'm going to the comedy store with
some friends tonight them whoa tonight I
won't be there tonight I'm supposed to
be there tonight
I mean that Thursday into Friday
Saturday who are you going with I'm
going with to my friends from college
haven't seen them in a hot minute so you
guys gonna see I don't know I just
thought take it yeah I just
I asked Derek for tickets Oh dope yeah
so shout out to Derek yeah just going
today cuz that's the only time that
works with all of our schedules how's
your sister doing good she's uh coming
pretty soon a couple weeks I really yeah
we're gonna go to [ __ ] nights [ __ ]
nice night for or night Oh horror said
or night you said were not for nights
too because which night is that is that
a to three men involved exclusively
Thursday nights or night or nice what
are you talking about [ __ ] nights in
Universal yeah well maybe there will be
some pours you never know oh yeah I mean
or night you get our attention
alright okay
this episode of the fighting kid comes
from manscaped he was number one in
men's below the belt groom and manscaped
offers precision engineered tools for
your family duels it's a skin safe
technology that's most important do you
ever cut your nuts yes some you those
things believe and make your sack do
your sack is yeah this has a trimmer it
will not snag your nuts okay that's very
important it's and if you're gonna walk
with dreadlocks and dingleberries
that's discus trim that [ __ ] up get
wimps off right now free shipping with
the code fighter at manscape calm always
use the right tools for the job your
balls will thank you I also have the
crop preserver and anti chafing ball
deodorant and moisturizer you put
deodorizing under your armpits why not
on your nutsack dude you give your nuts
a Philly fade I'll give your nuts in
Philly fade you Thompson off and free
shipping fade and free shipping with the
coach fighter at manscape combats plane
first off with Free Shipping at
manscaped escaped has in code Spyder SCA
PE D comm manscaped dude i watch
football I watch UFC in know what else I
watch with my bank account because I'd
be betting I'd be winning lost a lot
this weekend all right Browns let's
figure it out dude
all right Broncos you're awful so I'm
gonna quit betting on them either way
dude
my bookie makes betting on games so much
fun and so much easier the smart thing
to do is go to my bookie dot AG no one
gives you more ways to win than they do
my bookies got the fastest payouts and
better lines in any sports book period
I've been betting a long time man I use
these guys they paid me alright
do the smart thing if they're gonna bet
football if you're gonna bet if you guys
are gonna bet sure ya bet with my bookie
put your knowledge to the test and make
some money use promo code fight order
activate the offer that's promo code
fighter visit my bookie dot AG
today yo you win you get paid join now
and my bookie will double your first
deposit my bookie AG today
first woman okay so to Dutch men came to
America wanting to be a part of the area
51 raid and a couple days ago they tried
to go by themselves they parked a car
had a bunch of cameras and drones with
them and they ended up getting caught
trying to break into area 51 they tried
to make an apology video saying that
they didn't know what they were doing
they thought it was a was a joke but it
was very apparent that they were
actually trying to break in so now
they're sentenced to originally they
were sentenced to a year in American
prison but it got reduced to three days
and they have to pay a fine now okay
just for being dumb asses yeah the
government they got yeah you guys are
idiots yeah hey I can't believe people
actually doing it scroll over to do you
guess anyone see what's going on it's
gross yeah it's a birthmark it's just
what's called a scrum I'm aware that I'm
looking at the says Navy confirms that
the otter oh yeah that's he saw this
already though oh yeah if you're right
but they kind of did already they kind
of big they let it go on like CNN before
they said yeah the Navy actually is
putting this out there all they know
what's Ailin yeah and then scroll down
to the next one
Nick Carter seeks restraining order
against brother over increasing alarm
behavior yeah you see you guys have that
have you seen that Aaron card we've seen
it now if he had like he has a bunch he
wants to get guns now he was trying to
buy guns yeah but no Nick card is the
big one yeah so Aaron cars their cars
the looting someone that's trying to get
gun he's also buy right yeah gender he
came out as bi he got really soaking in
it sickly he was also a like a meth
addict I think he has some issues
careers Marquez right yeah drug issue
what James he didn't he's threatened to
kill Nick Carter's like unborn son and
his wife
so big cars like I gotta get restraining
orders Jesus and then yeah
where's Nick said his brother had
confess about having thoughts of harming
Nick's pregnant wife lura oh my god is
that him right there the guy with the
mental hell is got it under control
wait this from Nick Carter who's the
older one who's the successful one after
careful consideration my search angel I
regret that we are required to seek
retain order against her brother Aaron
and Latvians increase wearing behavior
confession
intention of killing my pregnant wife
and I'm one child we were left no choice
which is why would he post that I don't
know what because I think he's just
because he's brought Aaron's blast
everything out so he's probably gonna
punch of medications he's a he's bipolar
heard bipolar schizophrenic probably
yeah yeah everyone's just going through
some really bad times
that's not wait this is let me see what
a gent oh that's her who was leading the
me to moment and then [ __ ] a
seventeen-year-old yeah that she was
leading in remember she looks different
here oh you're back stronger than before
huh what about the fact that you are
total Haeju and oh she was the mean
witch you the one damned any Bourdain
she sucks
yeah hater she's all tatted up and so
but they're just [ __ ] a young boy
right yeah yeah yeah so what's one
another leading the whole thing and now
she's you know before she never lost her
Court well that's good yeah she's an
[ __ ] yeah I don't like her that's her
that's where she's recognized dude she's
so full of [ __ ] yikes
well what happened the factories but
what mmm sevens you know how
relationship was younger she been
questioned if what else we got me lived
in and I'm here first this bad boy here
we go so do you guys remember a woman
bailing r.kelly out yeah a couple months
ago he was being held and there was a
woman who says that she was his friend
and she actually bailed him out and paid
$100,000 so he would be able to go and
kind of get his businesses in order
before he would get charged and she
really thought that he was innocent and
said he was gonna get out regardless of
whether I put up this bail money or not
and he's a friend so I'm gonna help him
out and at the time she wouldn't confirm
or deny whether the money was from our
Kelly or from her and now that our Kelly
is not going to be getting out
she wants her money back and she had her
lawyer go to the judge and asked to have
her money returned to her and the judge
is like Nick don't work that way yeah
because he's got a bunch of child
support money back no she is not and she
knew that upon signing a waiver that's
[ __ ] up though cuz she doesn't and
that's a lot of money for probably this
person why does she do it though she
said that she was good friends with our
Kelly and truly believed that he was
innocent obviously I get that good of
friends but after she did that her
businesses went down she had a
restaurant and a babysitting business
that just went under well it's a lot of
money man it is like a babysitting
business yes I probably the worst thing
has more fear
that's [ __ ] the judge to give her
he's going away for a long time right
very long time well here's the other
thing that documentaries what made
everything pop mm-hmm a documentary on
it was it life I'm not what I mean it
was lifetime
I remember when he had done this with a
fourteen-year-old never I was like why
what's going happen right I told why he
went away
all right paid her off but how the state
is like this is a 14 year old I don't
know next one yeah shot at dark Kelly
okay that's a good way so a 50 year old
Long Island judge just pled guilty for
raiding his neighbor's home he broke
into a 23 year olds home who used to
work in the state office it's not
clarified whether she works directly
under him but she loved lived right next
to him he used to periodically break
into her home and take her dirty panties
from her hamper and come back home real
freak they found out that someone was
breaking into her home the police came
and actually caught him running out with
her panties stuck in his jacket pockets
people are freaks dude I've never been
no no no I can't break into somebody's
house either get their dirty judge he's
done this or other time so this guy's a
real freak well their people are just
into that and I just into it
Oh mental illness that's yeah his
attorney is claiming that he has a
mental illness sure
yeah no [ __ ] there's there's nothing of
anything like like I'm into like I mean
I don't know everybody has their weird
fetishes that the problem is you can't
break in just pay her for her dirty Anna
where exactly I'm sure was your pig
become mouth spit this sounds like a
[ __ ] compulsion like one of those
things like you know Mozilla it's like
the same sexual disorder that some
people have they have to break in get
into a closet when somebody's home and
jerk off okay or just or do it jerk off
and then leave because it's like a
thrill there's Sarah killers that go
back to the murder sites and Jack 100
watts yeah they get off it's how they
catch and they recreate that's a lot
that's other youth catcher in the sphere
killers my other side catching that's
cool and I could do with any more sure
but that first that's how they caught a
bunch of them cuz they'd go back the
size Jack [ __ ] crazy
you'll find him jerking off in his car
to it Richard Walter says yeah got your
ass I think that's how they caught the
Queen River murder some jerking off in
his car
Green River River but they they have
those uh panties in Japan right stain
them I don't know what I was thinking
just some skid marks I'm sure fellas
that you think DME and you know you get
some guys yeah I'm getting it deals now
I'm just joking but I'm sorry I know
when I draw every now and then you can't
help it now a couple of racetrack marked
out the back you feel me I keep my
whistle clean it's tough man yeah but
day yeah anyways next one yeah Jenny
Kevin guys ever offer to buy your socks
or undies yes recently yes unfortunately
you don't want so I'm good even if
you're the guy was like dude grand give
me a song here's the thing nobody offers
that amount of money though it's always
a geology yeah like seven dollars like
have you you haven't includes shipping
and handling
you haven't included tax you have
included what any of that too much work
expert grand though grands a pretty good
deal you do have a deal
hit me up if you're serious I'll think
about it
grand so Kevin Hart is currently facing
a sixteen
our lawsuit from the woman that was in
the sex tape with him in 2017 originally
when the sex tape came out she and her
lawyer weren't going to press charges
against Kevin because they said that he
was also a victim in the situation and
now she's coming out saying that the
person who recorded the sex tape is
working with Kevin Hart and they wanted
publicity for his irresponsible tour
that's what she's claiming that oh yeah
cuz he wanted to risk his entire family
and fortune on getting caught with some
chicken head leave kevin hart alone and
she knew the people involved in this I
mean snakes her money is that me I'd
love to see that 16 well that's what she
looks like
yeah yeah click on her which one this
one friend of Mines friends with her I
think she looks really good in this
picture brought one oh she's hot on all
of them she looks like God what's her
[ __ ] name she ain't in the cent no
somebody's guilty for being Hearst
looking for money uh God what's her name
Marissa from she's in hitch the girl
hitch Gosselin des little be that Eva
Mendes vibe better body though he or she
does yeah that's my she's smoked it dude
it's a sex party of Kevin Hart the
biggest rock star in the world so yeah
yeah we what's that what daddy likes
dude 60 million 69 oh so it hurt my
feelings for 60 million yeah she's in
smoke show that person I would also get
that person says her lawyer scumbags
loser Laura I believe it's that woman
who represents all women like this Lisa
bloom yeah I'm sure she's standing up
for she seems great it's all about money
yeah how does a great [ __ ] human
being I know you did have were you I
hear ya best like 60 nice great job
right in the car - you'll have to pay
her off just to shut her up ya little
five mil make it go away enjoy your
money
that's why will it happen huh oh that's
nice that's a 60 male in the cell for
two or three home girls get paid or less
and rightfully so what huh no keep going
chin I told you this Brennan that I took
a testosterone test we didn't talk about
is it negative what do you guys do they
happen is around 150 I say it's 300
what's normal though 300 it's hard to
tell what's I can't tell by this do
different reasons the stuff that yeah
there's one can tell what did they tell
you show you the results right here now
I'm not a doctor I just play one I don't
know how to do this either I don't not
even like understand what this is but
let me log in real quick there's no they
tell you anything they said I have to be
on a phone call there's like a you know
free phone call that I have to do later
oh oh you're in the normal so it's
normal well I don't get it free
testosterone but that's good hunting for
your good dude
no more rage what a crazy range 49.95
now if you got a little trt I'm
definitely understand French kinetic
over here you'd be you be pry in the
higher range above 185 free Tesla you
say you I said 300 so that's free
testosterone is different than different
and then between the range yeah so
different okay is there anything else so
that's all that's pretty much it can you
click on see more details
mm-my they just tell you about free
Tesla and I'd love to get mine tested
where'd you do that but this is just
that a CVS kit you just spit it in you
send it off you know there's a bunch not
blood DNA DNA of saliva is a good is a
good test actually by her blood is
better lecture yeah wait I do want to
take a blood one yeah blood - way more
cake plate all right well I guess I'm
normal I was hoping to be lower so I can
get some tea Artie hey you only Clinic
just say you have headaches and they
give you tea I do have headaches there
you go oh [ __ ] alright so Suicide Squad
- has named some of their casts and Pete
Davidson's part of it love people all
people yeah integers right I don't even
think he's posting to social media
anymore I haven't heard from kind of
went away with all that he was
the only newest thing is he's dating
that girl from the movie guys just went
to watch keeping once upon a time in
Holly Hollywood who's he did the young
girl from euphoria whatever the blonde
one from Sydney is her name
yeah no no it's the it's a young girl
she has a famous father I think I'll
fight you right here Judd Apatow his
daughter mom no she's way too young
wait you might be hurried to her
Margaret quali dude he gets so many
chicks big dick energy the biggest dick
energy you know it's [ __ ] boy fault
though that's series day so it's my time
yeah let me see she's daughter to Andie
MacDowell your anymore
oh I don't rank relative over her movie
oh yes she's one of the men she's part
of the Manson Family yeah yeah but this
time a Pete Davidson fan dude I like the
way dresses I love that shirt heels legs
there's like the dunking basketballs
damn those are some skinny legs but the
fat dick though dude I don't know man
I'll tell you the fat there sure that's
why Ariana Grande said and she used to
hooked up with Big Sean how do you
thought big do you think Big Sean is
Callen he's doing pretty well Big Sean's
five six why do you think they call him
Big Sean oh no man I'm not gonna [ __ ]
Detroit bazooka okay hey she's right
bazooka dude you call it a Detroit bazoo
from Detroit bro what's your [ __ ]
mouth
yeah dude get the I'm proud of him just
keep doing it yes do you know me yeah
how do you know uh just around is he is
he hanger I've never seen him once or he
goes there sparingly huh
I don't know we've been cool there's no
I uh
no world New York no Fahrenheit life but
he comes out here to is he saw a snow yo
yeah he's great man I've always been a
fan of you has been nice to me it was
great to me sweet oh yeah I love people
what else you got
I love his grace our together he started
the big dick energy area grande started
with him he just does look like he might
have a big dick I don't know why he just
does like lanky you know lanky yeah
I lose a big dick energy counselor
slinky [ __ ] boy falls in though dude I
don't know what that means
[ __ ] and a [ __ ] winter looking forward
to that
yeah don't look at me like that that's
good thank you stop stop staring at me
like you're looking at me kind of it for
a long time
sorry Mitch what you be part of [ __ ] boy
I am and that bothers me mr. hot girls
summer though you know like you were
there man
that was hot girl summer you're part of
hot girls oh yeah for a minute
summer's over though you know yeah
Felicity Huffman these Court after
sentencing 14 days in prison
yes yes prison time oh yeah well yeah
it's gonna be loosey-goosey though it's
still 14 days two weeks in prison
I heard her where she's gonna be serving
her time is like a different type of
prison sentence that so that like will
give her cappuccinos and ChaCha oh yes
that's it
if she's not serving like Aaron
Hernandez [ __ ] she's not Swedish prison
she's doing what Martha Stewart's doing
yeah yeah 14 days 250 hours community
service that's that's nothing all the
fines there it's more the embarrass me
it's more than just dealing like this
it's you've been you're being publicly
shamed say what BEC you from full house
and me a little bit of trouble though
cuz yeah let's see Huffman went guilty I
[ __ ] up my bat in the judgement you up
least you acknowledge it cool Becky from
Full House says nah [ __ ]
no she's got a lot more money hundred
fifty good yeah this was just wanting
conspiring to pay 15 grand this one was
just SAT I it's the same one day at your
penis her husband is the guy who started
Massimo they've got some mone
it's not yeah no matter this man dude
Becky is delicious cute Angie she's a
her dude her daughter
dude dude speaking of daughters do you
see Ireland Baldwin on the outs bolt
Baldwin roasts know Jesus talking about
cringy what it was just harshest [ __ ] oh
there's oh my god daughter yeah it was
did you ever hear his voice mail with
her called her fat little pig hilarious
she locked up if you hurt the daughter
yeah he's so awesome though
I heard the roast was hilarious dude
she's not drifting killed it but also
heals who's her mom okay miss Nikki
Glaser he's a place on fire she did set
on fire
Nikki Glaser killed it oh that's
Basinger she was religious that's Batman
women of all time that's Batman's girl
yeah
damn I dated a girl who looked like her
yeah but yeah but not her just as hot
mmm hey just as hot no oh yeah oh yeah
Cindy Crawford's my number one was like
classic hot young Cindy Crawford even
now did you think Cindy Crawford's
daughter spitting image without loud
scurvy but five-o again not but okay she
looks like someone else she looks very
young she looks like that Bush girl
selfie airs on her some girl absolution
in doing it dude Cindy Crawford paint me
Vera coca-cola commercials oof wasn't it
Pepsi no coca-cola her husband's a
billionaire with George Clooney they
started that tequila company in he stops
front or not Selena Gomez Oh was Pepsi
remember Pepsi Claire yep certain Asian
place oh not here like in Japan it's
still yeah that makes sense
not here though god damn it freeze
there's a long time ago though dude that
was it would go to Cindy Crawford bikini
oh I see what's oh I know what's
happening there's gotta be because
you've been giving out horrible example
of hot women like no who's got a do-over
all and at any time in a career whether
some husband early yes oh that yeah yeah
no [ __ ] cuz Halle Berry will just
acknowledging this dude now Sonny
younger yeah she's my she looks great
but um doesn't matter what
when she was younger no flat for me a
little skinny and flat a really good top
left one or the really flat go to bottom
one for my dad no more
oh I tap alright I tap I [ __ ] up I
test top five all-time bro she is top
five I'll give that to you
I get that tan good game in I don't care
let me see some more of those pictures
yeah take my pants off this told you to
do whoo yes I saw him Santa Monica bout
three years ago breath take go that one
not Kirby enough rice Yeah right there
chin all right man I give up dude I'm
sorry look at that that's a good it's
America yeah I like that
yeah that's America she's American she
looks like another planet with that yeah
sounds a large French we say sound
disaster friend Mon just alright what
else you got this girl and her mom are
claiming that she the little girl her
brain resets her memory in her brain
resets every two hours
oh she's she makes she wakes up on June
11th every single day oh this 50 first
dates that Adam Sandler just came out
this story came out when Rob was in here
too but we didn't do kind of that so
didn't perfect because he's yeah mmm-hmm
he's the guy with the mop wig with all
the kids yeah I enjoyed that with Rob I
enjoyed Rob because you don't want
really tied I want to talk comedy stuff
but you know he just interesting dude
yeah me too I like Rob yeah me too you
want to I got a story real quick sure
it's just 50 first date for real life
though but it's it seems like it's so
hard for me to believe
oh no sceptical Chin's out I guess she's
gonna make money I guess they do have a
GoFundMe account it is a condition the
doctors can't figure it out but then
since that she's on the news all these
doctors from around the world are trying
to find out what's going on how'd you
get the head injury
someone's crowd-surfing kicked her head
at school every two hours her memory
resets and each morning she wakes up
scared and confused
and I have a calendar on my door and I
look in September and I'm like whoa when
she wakes up in the morning she thinks
it's June 11th that's the day Riley was
accidentally kicked in the head and
after dozens of seizures and countless
hospital visits the Horner's still there
piece of [ __ ] no I'm not seeing a piece
of [ __ ] see it's just the firing if how
can they detect it though chin last week
and she probably has no idea and we tell
her every day but she doesn't have an
idea you're a bad person listen to this
I'm a terrible human and like people
just don't understand they're this it's
like a movie I will have no recollection
of this and suppertime
I hope you don't say suppertime oh you
were on the news what it's changed
everything for the former athlete and
scholar everything's more complicated
when you just can't remember Randy told
us that she made just be like this
forever girl who should be in the most
memorable time of her life it's just
hiding memories and I'm just really like
scared it's to Illinois you're a bad
person I'm not a bad person it's just
time you said she deserves to be this
way yeah so I think issues crowd-surfing
but that's right girl for me if you guys
want to donate if you guys really
passionate about this she's like you're
not the only one who's gonna blow this
house there's really seven hundred
dollars in child ory and and give her
some money
look what it says the headlight help
Riley remember her brain resets every
two or a 17-pound hundred eighteen
dollars what are they gonna do with the
money well okay so you get 15 grand we
can do with it
well can't buy a new brain she gonna do
with it buy more calendars Thunder
calendars you know she's like uh I buy
like whatever this time today I'm not
gonna remember anything like just I
don't know it just seems weird no you're
a [ __ ] all right you have a my herbal
person that's her over stereo this is
not that great this Edie buck who's a
very famous Democratic donor
he's had three people OD at his house
three black guys right yeah yeah two
people up two people actually died but
the one right now recently was just a
bad overdose of course yeah hooks up
scheduled to be arraigned today
prosecutors are recommending bail be set
at four million dollars anyways
that's a man damn buck that's the most
recent yoga no no no I was just saying
like I don't know it's a drug den I
would say it's a guy who nobody defined
among young black dudes who do drugs
he's like I got drugs for you I got this
little area briefcase a lot of it's
fentanyl they mixed fentanyl that's what
killed my ass good for you the you know
they showed what fentanyl what overdose
can kill like a hundred people they
showed it I mean how much seriously
talking about a spec on seriously could
kill hundred people what it looked up
fentanyl how could you know that with
tops yeah if they have to have these
super thick gloves on yes if they reach
into something this retinol it kill them
get their hand that's out young people
are just so strong gets their mixing
that it's a thousand times more powerful
than morphine a thousand times damn well
I know about this I don't know dude
tough one
no how strong is fentanyl and there
might be a picture on a penny we're just
talking about it
click on how strong his fellow and maybe
something will pop up see you typed in
the okay you have to be exposed to the
gas uh-huh powder hmm yeah I'm sure
powder if it gets me a nose [ __ ] yeah
there you'll click on that see solely a
fentanyl leave that
leave the little swatch the hell and so
they mix it with the heroin so this
white killed Mac Miller is they mixed
his heroin with fentanyl and he doesn't
know he just thinks this is regular
dosage but it's actually way strong cuz
feting all in there but they don't tell
you that because you don't know if you
inject it it's game over man that kids
in prison now the kids he's [ __ ] super
[ __ ] lord have mercy
and fentanyl is a prescription
medication - yeah that [ __ ] opioid
it's free so on Purdue pharmaceuticals
there they filed for bankruptcy
yeah I've hidden some of their money
that family was very apparently was
really instrumental in marketing opioids
oxycontin as not addictive it's like
here's God it is a good drug so how
about I'll put that on the left on that
picture the left is a lethal lethal dose
of heroin right kind of a lot crazy on
the right is a lethal dose of fentanyl
that's a come on that's aspects respect
so you have morons mixing these with
their heroin and stuff but they don't so
just that little bit so think about the
risk you take if you're doing here take
the [ __ ] heroin dude that's why I
stick to 15 stick to black cocaine dude
yeah what if what if this got a knock
okay oh god please don't what else we
got this here bo and yang first Asian
variety is the first Asian Asian
American to be cast on SNL huh it's cool
uh Rob Schneider I mean I guess this is
full aegeon then yeah that's cool hold
up why Smoky Hill High School this guy's
from my hood what yes he's from Denver
do now you like oh yes
and look what his high school thing said
most like to be cast on Senate life dude
crazy a rival school smoky hill buffalos
always live on trail blade really yeah
Oh football bro
wow dude like a surprise little side
appearance with Sandro one ounce of sand
dude he's from Aurora you watch a little
bit of it yeah yeah yeah I just heard a
little bit of us you can see how he acts
this is supposed to be a kim jonghwan
and she's his translator I love it
that's so cool he's from Denver man [ __ ]
you I'm in Denver next week by the way
next week I'm in top of this
twenty-seventh and twenty-eighth tapper
improv on 2728 let me say my date I'm in
tap on the 2720 why he gets more than
that that's right at the tap my improv
is that it dudes assure us you're in
Tampa this Friday Saturday there's a
final Saturday I'm at the Comedy Store
Laugh Factory that cash yeah I'm in
Houston Friday Saturday T shows Friday
to show Saturday shows are almost sold
out I've no comp so get them while you
can tip at kake.com the next week
Denver Thursday Friday Saturday Comi
works downtown and then just announced
today Wilbur theater wait hold up it's
Foxwoods casino in Connecticut and that
is January 10th that's a Friday and then
I'm in Wilbur Boston theater and that is
January 11th presale just went on today
I'll post on my social media tea fat K
calm have tickets up my lazy ass
brothers in Indonesia on vacation so it
might take a few days to get the dates
up either way I lost my social media
that's it man see you guys in Houston
this week Denver next week t5k dot-com
for tickets Brian's in Tampa next week
yes I am I'm excited too cool man see
you there kids this is a fun kid route